>>> FOER DONALD TRUMP --
Y.S ON'T SAY WHAT THAT DECISIONE
PERS W WON'T BY IF HE  FIRST
LADY, NIA TRUMP. BENNETT JOINS E
JOININ OR BEIN DID YOUEA NOTNLI
E.
INTERESTED IG IN THEHITE S SHE'N
GOG G
FIRST LADY AGAIN.NOW SHE'S
E PUBLIC WRSNDBEG IN
TO DO IN THE FIR P.
S REO
CETERA.
PING HBAND WITH HI NO INTE
PERCEIVED, AS  K HIS
POLITICA
>>S NOT
>>
PEOPLE ARE UNDER T
THIS IS A
COUPLE THAT DOME , THEY DON'T
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
IN 2016 WHEN S W LIY DO CONSULTE
EV
EVENTSNDLIE ANSW
WAS NO SO OFTEAT PEOPLE ON
TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN JUSOPD
G TO BE A NO. ALWAYS
E THAT AGAINTIME AROUND.
YO A AVEN' SEEN HER
FIO DO. NOT REALLTAN OF THE BRE
SCE OF THE PM THAT A FORMER FIR.
RE
WORK THE IE HOUSE.EY CONTIE G F.
EVENAURAHAVE WORK  D
THE TIME AS T LADY.
IT'S BEEN ABOUSEVEN MONTHS
SINCE SHE LEFT HOUTHERE HANO AI.
NOT GOOD OR BAD, SHE'S JUST
OKI LLENGE
ER THAT PLATFORM FOR
HAVE TO FLNG OPPORTUNITY Y
MESSAG
BUT LIKE HER HUSBAND, SH AN
ANRICAN POTI HER HUSBANDAS OUT
SAYS THAT HE HASN'T HT R STRONGN
>> I WOULD SAY SEWHERE BETWEEN
99 AND 100%.I THINK HE'S DEFINI
IN 2024.
I HAD A GOOD CONVERSAT
HIM LAST
SEE HIMOTHER
LES HEREWORDS TO ME,UT
>> TT PRESIDENT IS GOING.
RUN AGAIN?
I R THAT HE IS HE ISUN RIGHT
RUNNING RIGHT NO THE
THAT HE'S KEEPRING, HE'S
EVYBED.
IT SEEMS VERY CLEAR THAT HIS
NEEDHTR ATTENTION
ABOVE EVERYTHING.
AND  THINGS LIKE
THIS ANDING PEOPLE AROUND Y THIT
R THAT HIS HEAD IS SVERY MH
PROCESS.
DOES THAT ATE TO HIM
ACTUALEI
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY COULD KNOW
THT THISS ATTEAND
INFLUENCE AS WELL.
HE CONTINUES TO RAISE MONED
THE REPUBLICANARTY AS
GETTG
THINGS IN PLESE WANTS THEM
TO BE. AND WHEN IT COMES
INFLUENCE, WKN THAT HE I
GETTN THESE
NG THOUGH N LEADS WANT HIM
Y ES,
STL
ENDORSING THESE PEOPLE.
EMEMBER BACK IN CPAC IN,
LIKE, FEBRUARYCOTT
LIKE LET'S ROL
CLEARAS MAYBE THE PMAHAIGHT BEN
E VIRGINIA OR'S RACTH BASRTY ISR
MOST LIKE TRUMP.MPTE THE
WHEN IT COMES TO THO